I've crossed paths with many during my
journey for True strength
I've also met my share of enemies
opponents I had to overcome
my journey knows no end I will continue
to do what I have always done
having no room
honestly I thought you were a complete
idiot
[Music]
Masters he was set up
I'm not nearly strong enough to chase
after a monster like that
it's probably worth looking into this
nice shawl business
[Music]
was it simply a trick of the senses
he attempted to set the world under his
field through violence
a veritable Mad Money
when you go looking for strength it's
not like a game
this journey doesn't have a real
attitude
six
[Music]